Bitte schön.
Ja, ich bräute ein paar Sekunden um meine Näsbogenforst zu bereiten. Darf ich vorbereiten?
Ja, bitte schön.
Ja, vielen Dank. Ja, ich bin bereit, können wir anfangen?
Ja, Herr Doktor, Sie sind Herr Doktor Wer?
Ergit. Ergit, E-R, Y-E-G-I-T.
Ja, so, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Umut Ergit und heute bin ich der Den Salbender Arzt auf dieser Station.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen gerne das Erskitsprich führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Ja, vielen Dank. Ich werde zuerst ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Personen stellen, dann kommen wir auch sofort zu Ihrem Beschwerden.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder eine Frage haben, bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Werner Siemens.
Werner Siemens. Werner ist eine Weibliche Name.
Nein, ein männlicher Name.
Ja, entschuldigung. Ja, Herr Siemens, könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vornamen und Nachnamen buchstavieren?
Mein Vornamen Werner wird geschrieben mit We, Emil Richard, Nordpol Emil Richard.
Ja.
Nachname Siemens, Siegfried, Ida Emil, Martha Emil, Nordpol Siegfried.
Okay. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
50 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Wie bitte?
Am 14.04.1974.
14.04.1974.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,76 m groß.
Wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja, so um die 85 kg.
Ja, Herr Siemens, was führt Sie heute zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe seit 4 Wochen Schmerzen in meinem Rücken.
Seit 3 Tagen habe ich Schmerzzunahme.
Und die Schmerzen sind seit 3 Tagen 10 auch in meinem rechten Bein.
Ja, ich muss dokumentieren. Alles war sehr wenig.
Okay.
Im rechten Bein.
Du außenseite, so an der Außenseite sozusagen.
Außenseite.
Ja, Herr Siemens, könnten wir zeigen, ob die Schmerzen in anderen Körperregionen ausstrahlen?
Ich habe sie auch außenseite und im rechten Bein bis Finger oder?
Finger ist in meiner Hand.
Entschuldigung.
Was ist das?
Rehe.
Aber nicht zu nehmen. Bei mir zieht der Schmerz nur bis zu meinem Knie.
Ja, okay. Bis Knie.
Im türkischen sagt man Finger für die Hand und für den Fuß, an Deutsch nicht.
Ja, ja. Entschuldigung.
Ich hatte mich durch meine Arbeitskollegin.
Ja, okay. Können Sie bitte die Schmerzen genau becheiben und durchkennen, wo er nennt, kribbeln?
Ich würde sagen, er ziehende.
Ziehende, ja, okay.
Der zieht von meinem Rücken, lendenwirbeln, bis in meinem Knie.
Okay.
Okay, wie starten die Schmerzen auf einer Schkale von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 unerträglichen Schmerzen entspricht?
Ja, ich würde sagen sieben.
Sieben.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen in der Oder versteckt?
Nee, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Okay. Könnten Sie ein Auslöser bemerken?
Nee, also kann ich mir nicht dran erinnern, dass etwas besonders passiert ist.
Okay. Ich meine, müssen Sie eine Schwersache heben oder tragen?
Ja, kann ich mich nicht erinnern. Das hat ja nicht stark begonnen.
Deshalb, seit 4 Wochen habe ich leichte Schmerzen.
Ja.
3 Tagen sind ich zugenommen, aber ich könnte nicht sagen, warum es ist.
Okay.
Okay, hatte Sie früher ein HMB-Schwerden?
Ja, nicht so schlimm wie jetzt ab und zu mal, aber nicht so...
Nur im Rücken hat man manchmal, wenn man irgendwas schwer hebt oder irgendwas.
Aber nicht so wie jetzt, 4 Wochen lang und jetzt noch schlimmer.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Taubkreis gefühlt in Ihrem Bein?
Ja, in meinem Bein habe ich keinen Taubkreis gefühlt.
Oder ein Schlür, Taubkreis gefühlt keine.
Leiden Sie unter Kraftlosigkeit?
Nein.
Kraftlosigkeit? Nein, würde ich nicht sagen.
Okay.
Nur, die Schmerzen sind stärker, wenn ich zum Beispiel mein Recht ist bei einem Hochheben.
Hochheben, okay. Hochheben, Recht.
Das heißt, wenn ich Treppen laufen will, habe ich Probleme.
Okay.
Ja, wie können Sie ohne Pause laufen?
Ja, habe ich nie geguckt, weiß ich nicht. Also es ist nicht schwierig, normal.
Okay, normal.
Ja.
Haben Sie Schwellung in Bein bemerkt?
Schwellung habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Schwellung, okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihr Rechtbein wehmet oder kalter als andere oder als normal?
Ja, ich habe nicht bemerkt, dass Ihr Rechtbein wehmet oder kalter als andere oder als normal?
Ne, das ist eine Temperaturunterschied, habe ich auch nicht bemerkt, mit anderen Existen.
Okay, haben Sie Hautfarbveränderung bemerkt?
Noch mal, was bemerkt?
Haben Sie Hautfarbveränderung bemerkt?
Hautfarbveränderung, nein.
Okay.
Ja.
Ja Herr Siemens, bis auf Obogenente beschwerden, haben Sie noch etwas ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Was ungewöhnlich?
Ne, das wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, okay.
Jetzt möchte ich zusammenfassen, seit vier Wochen haben Sie Schmerzen in Brücken
und seit drei Tagen verschlechtert die Schmerzen
und diese Schmerzen sind Siehent und Liege sieben von Seen.
Sie haben keine Taubreizgefühlkraftverlust,
oder Schwerung über Warmung, Kaltung.
Hab ich etwas verpasst oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Gleich hinzufügen, es liegen sieben von Seen, was eine Schmerzkala würde ich da noch erwähnen,
ans hinzufügen.
Wenn Sie sagen sieben von Seen, haben Sie es als sieben von Seen Apfel
oder sieben von Seen Apfel oder...
Ja, Schmerzintestät.
Ja, und unser Geschenkretau wird ca. 15 Minuten, noch 15 Minuten.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen aufhalten, oder darf ich Ihnen Medikamente geben?
Ne, das geht.
Ich habe es ja seit drei Tagen stark geschmessen,
aber ich habe ja heute noch eine Ibo genommen, das geht.
Ja, Ibo Profen, Sie haben einen genommen.
In welcher Dosierung haben Sie Ibo Profen einen genommen?
Ich habe zuhause 800 Milligramm.
Einmal 800 Milligramm.
Ja, bei Bedarf.
Also gestern waren es drei Stück, heute habe ich bis jetzt zwei eingenommen.
Zwei. Zwei Mal heute und gestern drei Mal.
Ja, so, ich meine, diese Medikamente, ihnen geholt von haben.
Ja, okay, vielen Dank.
Herr Siemens, ich habe Ihre Beschwerden verstanden
und ich werde mich bald um Ihre Beschwerden kümmern.
Jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer allgemeinen Gesundheit hinzustanden.
Wie hat sich Ihre Appetit in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Ne, nichts Besonderes.
Es ist gleich gut.
Okay, ja, das ist gut.
Okay, ja, sehr gut. Fühlen Sie sich fibrig?
Nein.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Nachschirchweiß oder Stilfrost?
Stilfrost, Nachschirchweiß, nein.
Okay. Haben Sie Schilderkeiten beim Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Ne.
Okay.
Das ist sehr gut bei mir.
Ja, sehr gut.
So, haben Sie Probleme bei Wasalasen oder Stilfrost?
Ne, auch nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ungewolle ab oder zu genommen?
Ne, auch nicht.
Okay.
Ja, vielen Dank, Herr Siemens.
Und jetzt, ich hätte einige Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte.
Leiden Sie unter irgendwelche dauerhafte Erkrankungen.
Ich meine Bluthochdruck.
Ja, ich nehme Medikamente in Bluthochdruck.
Bluthochdruck, seit wann leiden Sie an Bluthochdruck?
Seit zwei Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Im April nehme ich ein.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
10 Milligramm.
Nehmen Sie einmal täglich ein?
Ja, bald täglich morgens.
Okay.
Und sonst nehmen Sie irgendwer mit dem Kommentar dagegen?
Gegen Bluthochdruck?
Nein.
Leiden Sie an andere Krankheiten?
Franke, ne, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja.
Was für das Opel?
Ich bin, wo ich 18 Jahre alt war,
vom Fahrrad gefangen habe und habe mir über den Handgelenk gebrochen.
Handgelenk?
Ja, okay.
Nehmen Sie den Namen von Knogen, welcher gebrochen ist?
Außer in der...
Die Speiche im Bereich meines Handgelenkes.
Ja, okay.
Ja, wundern Sie, wer ist der?
Ja, der ist der.
Ja, okay.
Ja, wundern Sie schon wegen anderer Krankheiten operiert?
Andere Krankheiten, ja, meine Mandeln wurde entfernt.
Wann war das Opel?
Da war ich 7 Jahre alt.
Haben Sie 10?
Ich konnte nicht ganz verstehen.
7 Jahre alt.
Ja, okay.
Ja, außer diese Ramelpril und bei Bedarf über Profen
nehmen Sie andere Medikamente regeln Sie oder bei Bedarf ein?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien sowie Unverträglichkeiten bekamst?
Allergie ist bei mir Penicillin Allergie.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Damals, wo ich Kind war, hätte ich Atemnoten.
Ich weiß, kann mich nicht erinnern, aber meine Eltern sagten mir,
wo ich ein blindes Mandeln operiert wurde, hätte ich mit Atemnoten reagiert.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Leiden Sie in der Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, wenn ich die Klopherak nehme, dann habe ich Durchfall und Bauchschmerzen.
Genau.
Und Bauchschmerzen.
Ja.
Und Vollgeimpft?
Ich meine, ich habe ja auch Vollgeimpft.
Ja, ich hatte zu bitte keinen Corona gehabt, aber ich bin auch Vollgeimpft.
Vollgeimpft, okay.
Aber auch der anderen Kinderimpfungen und so weiter, also alle Impfungen gemacht bis jetzt.
Okay.
Hatten Sie in der letzten Zeit Unfall oder Verletzung?
Letzte Zeit nicht, nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit in Land oder Ausland gereist?
In Land oder Ausland, nein.
Okay.
Vor drei Wochen war ich im anderen Staat, Staat Bayern.
Wenn das Ausland ist, vielleicht dann...
Nein, das ist in Land, ich glaube.
Ja.
Die Bayern sehen das anders.
Ja, man kann sagen.
Ja, okay.
Herr Simes, wir sind fast fertig, aber ich hätte noch einige Fragen zu Ihren Allgemeingewohnheiten.
Rauchen Sie?
Rauchen nein, auch ich auch nicht.
Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu Sie?
Nein, auch nicht.
Haben Sie früher geraucht oder Alkohol getrunken können?
Nee.
Also, als jung war, habe ich ein paar Mal getrunken, aber das ist nicht regelmäßig.
Da war ich jung auf Partys, aber das sind so ein paar Jahre her, also ich trinke kein Alkohol.
Okay.
Haben Sie erfahren, wie es mit Drogen gibt?
Mit Drogen.
Ja.
Ich persönlich nicht, aber mein Freundeskreis, das sehe ich, was da los ist.
Ja, Hochstag ist sehr bekannt.
Ja.
So treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, regelmäßig.
Ich fahre Fahrrad und schwimme viel.
Fahrrad, Fahrrad und Schwimmen.
Immer fahren Sie Fahrrad oder schwimmen?
Wie noch mal?
Wie viel in einem Woche fahren Sie Fahrrad?
Ich würde sagen, habe ich nicht gerechnet, aber 200 Kilometer in der Woche ist meine Woche.
200 Kilometer.
In der Woche.
Ich fahre viel.
Ich fahre Fahrrad mit, nach der Arbeit.
Ich bin sehr sportlich.
Ja, als was arbeiten Sie?
Wie bitte?
Wie arbeiten Sie?
Ich arbeite in einem IT-Beruf.
Ich bin Diplom-Informatiker.
Management in IT-Bereich.
Ja.
Okay.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie schwimmen gehen.
Genau.
2 Mal die Woche.
2 Mal?
Ja, 2 Mal die Woche.
Okay.
2 Mal büchentlich, kann man auch sagen.
Ah, okay.
Herr Simes, sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Meine Eltern sind noch am Leben, ja.
Gott sei Dank.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, die nehmen Medikamente ein, aber sonst denke ich schon, dass sie gesund sind.
Ja.
Sie nehmen wegen seinem Bluthochdruck, nimmt der Medikament ein.
Der hat einen Blut-Ad-Ein-Vater.
Könnt ihr Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ja.
Leidet an Blut-Ad-Erhöhte-But-Ankung sozusagen,
aber der ist gut eingestellt, also zurzeit ist er nicht krank durch Medikament.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Mutter?
Er nimmt einen Blutverdunner, weil er einen Stand bekommen hat.
Dem geht es jetzt gut, stabil.
Meine Mutter ist übergewichtig und leidet öfters an Asthma-Anfall.
Übergewichtig und Asthma.
Weswegen kann ich nicht sagen.
Er hat irgendein Spray, der Sie öfters benutzt.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sind Sie Geschwister?
Entschuldigen Sie.
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Bruder ist eher gesund?
Ja, ich denke, er ist jünger als ich.
Ich denke, er nimmt keine Medikamente ein.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und habe drei Kinder.
Okay, so wohnen Sie zusammen?
Jawohl.
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Bis jetzt, ja.
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Wenn man meine Kinder fragen würde, würde sie sagen,
ich würde sie immer näher füllen, aber ansonsten sind die gesund.
Ja, ich habe auch drei Kinder.
Ich kann auch sagen.
Entschuldigen Sie, Herr Siemens.
Sie haben aber erledigt, aber ich konnte nicht ganz verstehen.
Ihr Vater leidet unter Bluthochdruck
und nimmt Brutverdünne wegen Herzkarteter.
Er hatte eine Herzkarteter, das wurde dann ein Sten gelegt.
Okay.
Vor zehn Jahren ungefähr.
Vor zehn Jahren, okay.
Aber aktuell leidet er nicht gut.
Damals hatte er ein Problem gehabt.
Ja, okay.
Herr Siemens, ich habe Ihre Beschwerden verstanden.
Und wie ich gesagt habe, werde ich bald um Ihre Beschwerden kommen möchten.
Herr Siemens, können Sie fragen, was ich wissen sollte?
Ich habe Fragen.
Wie geht es weiter?
Was passiert jetzt?
Wie lange dauert das alles?
Was machen Sie mit mir noch?
Können Sie mir helfen?
Was habe ich denn?
Was denken Sie, was ich habe?
Herr Siemens, ja, zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Und danach werde ich einige Massnahmen verfahren,
wie Brutabnehmen oder Bildgebende verfahren.
Was meinen Sie mit Bildgebenden verfahren?
Wird ein Foto von mir gemacht?
Ja, natürlich.
Nicht Ihr Foto, aber ein Foto von Ihrer Wirbelsäune.
Ihre Knochen meine ich.
Ich würde eine Röntgenabnahme entlassen.
Was ist das?
Ich würde eine Röntgen-Massnahme veranlassen.
Röntgenaufnahme?
Nein, das ist keine gefährliche Untersuchung.
Aber es ist ein strahlengewende Untersuchung.
Aber machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Unsere Geräte sind moderne und neue Geräte.
Und immer gut eingestellt.
So, wie Sie das sagen,
ist es keine gefährliche Situation.
Kann man dann sehen, ob ich einen Bandscheinvorfall habe?
Nein, man kann nicht genau wörtalen,
aber man kann mit einer Röntgen,
ob wir die Knochenbruch gibt,
oder eine Steno-Verhängung zwischen Wirbelsäulen gibt.
Aber man kann nicht einen Bandscheinvorfall bestätigen,
mit der Röntgen bestätigen, bestimmen.
Kann man nur Knochen beurteilen?
Knochen beurteilen, okay.
Ist das eine Aufnahme, wo man nicht den Knochen,
sondern auch Bandschein beurteilen kann?
Ja, man kann mit CT und MRT die Wirbelsäule genau beurteilen.
MRT wäre am besten.
Warum machen wir nicht gleich eine MRT Aufnahme?
Ist es gefährlich?
MRT ist kein gefährliches.
Aber wenn Sie Platzangst haben,
können Sie ein bisschen Angst haben.
Wenn Sie Platzangst haben,
müssen Sie in einer Hölle ca. 20 Minuten liegen.
Wenn man Platzangst hat, wäre es ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber natürlich kann ich Ihnen Beruhigungsmittel verordnen.
Das macht die Situation besserer.
Einfacher.
Warum machen wir nicht gleich eine MRT und Röntgenaufnahme?
Ich habe nicht ganz verstanden.
Röntgen ist einfacher durchzuführen.
Man kann schnell ein Röntgen durchführen.
Man kann die schwierigen Situationen
oder gefährlichen Situationen wie ein Knochenbruch beurteilen.
Es ist schwierig, eine MRT zu erreichen.
Jeder Krankenhaus hat keine MRT.
Manchmal können Sie überwiesen werden,
um eine MRT durchzuführen.
Woanders dahin, meinen Sie.
Das ist eine aufwändige Untersuchung.
Dann haben Sie gesagt, es wird Blut abgenommen.
Bildgebende Verfahren werden gemacht.
Dann habe ich es unterbrochen.
Das ist eine aufwändige Untersuchung.
Ich bin gesetzlich.
Als ob Sie privat versichert werden, wäre es einfacher,
um eine MRT durchzuführen.
Die Privatpatienten wieder mal.
Immer diese zwei Klassengesellschaft.
Danke schön.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Nein, ich habe eine Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Nein, noch mal.
Meistens besser, wenn Sie den Satz neu anfangen.
Nein.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Nein, ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Es gibt.
Aus meiner Seite.
Aus meiner Seite gibt es Fragen.
Ja, aus meiner Seite.
Ich bin kein grammatikalischer Mensch.
Das ist immer los.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen so.
Aber wir müssen die Differenzialdiagnose ein paar Differenzialdiagnose sehen.
Und deswegen...
Macht man das nicht bei dem Oberarztgespräch,
diese Differenzialdiagnose?
Ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Urin- und Stuhlprobleme haben.
Sie müssen oft auf der Toilette oder haben Sie bemerkt,
dass die Urin oder Stuhl etwas Farberänderungen haben.
Nein, nicht.
Es ist immer so.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie nicht auf der Toilette haben.
Sie waren ein anderer Arzt?
Ich hatte früher auch guten Schmerzen gehabt, aber deswegen war ich nicht bei einem Arzt.
Das war immer kurzfristig.
Ich habe einen, zwei Tage gedauert.
Ich habe im Profi genommen, ein bisschen Wärme gemacht und da war es gut.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Aktuell dauerhaft.
Der Schmerz ist immer da, seit drei Tagen.
Seit vier Wochen sind das kommende Schmerzen gewesen.
Bei bestimmten Situationen, wenn ich zum Beispiel liege, habe ich keinen Schmerz.
Aber wenn ich aufstehen möchte, wenn ich lange stehe, habe ich öfter Schmerzen, aber nicht permanent.
Seit drei Tagen habe ich einen permanenten Schmerz, der mehr oder weniger ist.
Die ich mit Medikament gut im Griff habe.
Abhängig davon, dass die Schmerzen beim Bewegung verschlägt hätten, sich helfen.
Ja, bei Bewegung, also in den letzten drei Tagen ist egal, was ich mache, Schmerzen.
Das ist ein Peppern des Schmerzes.
Aber davor war es belastungsabhängig gewesen, wenn ich etwas gehoben habe, wenn ich vom Sitz und vom Liegen aufstehe.
Die ersten vier Wochen, die letzten vier Wochen war es so.
Das ist rechte Beine.
Haben Sie leicht Bewegung oder?
Noch mal.
Wenn ich meinen Ball hochhebe, hatte ich Schmerzen gehabt.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich treppen hochlaufen will, habe ich Probleme.
Okay, danke schön.
Das war meine Frage.
Kollegen haben gefragt, dass Sie einige Auslöse bemerkt haben.
Sie haben gesagt, nein, aber ich muss betont fragen, hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Unfall hatte ich keinen gehabt.
Also ich kann erinnern, dass ich irgendwas Schweres gehoben habe oder dass ich gestürzt bin.
Das ist irgendwie da.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ist Ihnen schwindelig oder Kopfschmerzen?
Nein, ich habe keine Kopfschmerzen und es mir ist auch nicht schwindelig.
Haben Sie Übelkeit und Erbrochen?
Erbrechen habe ich auch nicht.
Okay, danke.
Können wir als Hausgesicht beginnen?
Von meiner Seite aus, ja.
Von Kollegen weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin bereit.
Okay.
Guten Abend Herr Oberwärts.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, wissen Sie mal los.
Deswegen bin ich da. Bitte schön.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Werna Siemens ist 40 Jahre alt, 1,76 m und wird 85 kg.
Er ist verheiratet und hat drei Kinder, die gesund seien.
Er lebt mit seiner Familie.
Er arbeitet als Manager in IT Bereichen.
Er hat uns wegen der Zeit für die Woche 5.
Rücken schmerzen mit Ausstrahlung.
Er lebt mit Ausstrahlung bis sehr.
Und er...
Laterale, außersteig.
Ja, in der Seite.
Bis ins Knie, nicht bis ins Zehe.
Sie haben nur gefragt bis ins Zehe.
Bis ins Knie, lateral.
Okay.
Der Patient berichtet, dass die Schmerzen vor 4 Wochen langsam abgetreten seien.
Aber sie hätten drei Tage verschlechtert.
Bis in 5, hat sie verschlechtert.
Ja, sie haben sich verschlechtert.
Und er teilte mit, dass die Schmerzen bei sieben von 10 auf einer Schkale liegen würden.
Er hat auch erwähnt, dass die Schmerzen sich mit hochheben und bewegen verschlechtert hätten.
Wenn er etwas hochhebt, oder was meinen Sie damit?
Abtuxiön oder abtuxiön?
Abtuxiön?
Ja, beim Flexion.
Flexion im Hüftgelenk, meinen Sie?
Ja.
Ich glaube, Sie sind Oberarzt.
Sie haben immer recht.
Sie können morgen anfangen, bei uns für immer zu arbeiten.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ja, und wir haben gestern 3 Mal 8 Milligramm über Profen und heute 2 Mal 800 Milligramm über Profen dagegen eingenommen.
Und es hat ein bisschen gewollt.
400 Milligramm, 2 Tabletten, einmal oder 800 Milligramm?
800 Milligramm.
Ich habe zuhause 800 Milligramm Tabletten.
Ja, 800 Milligramm.
Sie haben auch mal aufgenommen.
Sie hat auch im Profen.
Ja, ja, eingenommen.
Und Taubheitsgefühl, Kraftverlust.
Parastäsie?
Ja, Parastäsie entschuldigen Sie.
Ja, Parastäsie, Parastäsie, Schwellung bedenkt.
Überwarmung oder Kaltung würden von der Patientin,
die Patientin, die Patientin, fernheit vegetativ an dem Nest ist unauffällig.
Ja, als Forterkrankungen.
Leider der Patient, seit 2 Jahren, an Arterialhypertone und dagegen,
neben Erwamübbil, 7 Milligramm, einmal Mogens,
er wurde ein, ja ein, entschuldigung, ja ein.
Er wurde, ja mit Alter von 15 Jahre alt,
wurde er wegen Radiosfraktur operiert.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Er wurde operiert oder bei ihm operiert?
Noch mal, sagen Sie den Satz nochmal bitte.
Er wurde von 15 Jahre alt,
wurde er wegen Radiosfraktur operiert.
Er hat diese Teile Radiosfraktur operiert,
weil er gesagt hat Handgelenk.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Er wurde oder bei ihm, Patientin,
wurde, bei ihm?
Bei einem Patientin wurde eine Operation durchgeführt,
aber er wurde operiert.
Bei den Patientin wurde eine Operation durchgeführt.
Tamam sagen, aber das ist so lang,
der andere ist besser.
Ja, und?
Welche Operation?
Die Stahlradiosfraktion.
Ja.
Ja, und mit Alter von 7 Jahre alt,
wurde er tonsillektomiert.
Aus der Erwamübbil und bei Bedarf über Profen
und mit der Erwamübbil nicht mit Medikamenten.
Er reagiert allergisch gegen Penicillin
und reagiert darauf mit Dispno.
Er hat Unfertiglichkeiten gegen Diplofen
und reagiert mit Diab und Bauchmerzen.
Er ist voll geimpft
und hat eine Reise,
eine Mese, sein Lea.
Er ist, er sei kein Raucher
und er nimmt keine Alkohol zu sich.
Als Jung habe er 2-3 Mal getrunken,
aber zurzeit trinkt er nichts.
Als Jung, würde ich nicht sagen, als junger Mensch habe er.
Als Jung ist so ein bisschen alleine, das Wort.
Als Jugendlicher oder als junger Mensch, könnte man sagen.
Als Jugendlicher habe er 2-3 Mal getrunken,
aber zurzeit nehme er keine Alkohol zu sich.
Er habe keine Erfahrungen mitgezogen.
Er fährt Fahrrad etwa 200 Kilometer
im Einwohler
und er geht jetzt mit dem Sivaymal pro Bohler.
An Familie der Anämenese leidet sein Vater
an Artigerpipertonien und nimmt
er, ah ja, nimmt er
Blutverdünne, ihr habt vergessen.
Blutverdünne,
ja, nehme eher Blutverdünne
wegen einer Standsimplantation.
Also, man kann sagen, der hat eine KK Erkrankung.
Coronareherskrankheit.
Coronareherskrankheit, okay.
Er nimmt wegen der Blutverdünne ein.
Ja, er nimmt wegen der Blutverdünne ein.
Und,
Ihr Mutter sei übergewichtig und leide unter Postmarsch.
Übergewichtig, wie wird sie das in Arschwache nennen?
Arsch,
Carbon, Obes,
Bunat,
Es verdient nicht.
Petrileibik.
Petrileibik hat nein.
Adipositas.
Adipositas, ja.
Adipositas, sie leidet an Adipositas.
Ja, an Asiwutas.
Ja,
und,
ja, der Patient habe einen Bruder, die gesund sei.
Der gesund sei?
Ja, gesund sei.
Der Bruder ist gesund, nicht die Schwester.
Die könnte gesund sein.
Ja, gesund sei.
Ja, und,
die erhobenen Analystischen Angaben durchtun ...
Die drei Kinder seien auch gesund.
Ja, die drei Kinder seien auch gesund.
Ja, er habe drei Kinder, er hat drei Kinder und die seien auch gesund.
Ja.
So,
die erhobenen Analystischen Angaben durchtun
am Ästen, eine Dispulverwärtschutz hin.
Ja.
Und als Differenzialdiagnose
habe ich Osteroporos, Spinal, Stenos,
Äh, Arthritis,
Äh, Muskulverspannung
äh,
und Muskulverspannung.
Ja.
Ja, und ...
Also, wie würde die eine Erkrankung nennen,
wenn jemand im Ländengürmesäule Schmerzen hat
und der in den Beinen ausstrahlt?
Kennst du den Namen dafür?
Jemand hat ...
im LBS-Bereich Schmerzen
und hat eine Schmerzaustrahlung in einem Bein.
Wissen Sie, wie das heißt?
Wollen Sie äh ...
Wir müssen ...
äh ...
Ländengürmesäule ...
sind drum.
Herz heißt Lumbalgie.
Ja, Lumbalgie.
Und wenn jemand eine Ausstrahlung in dem Bein hat,
dann nennt man das eine Lumboechialgie.
Also, ja.
Also, eine Lumboechialgie, also, man kann sagen,
ein Discosproletz ...
wissen Sie noch nicht, Sie haben ja noch keinen MRT gemacht.
Ja.
Das ist eine Fachdiagnose, aber ...
eine Lumboechialgie oder eine akute Lumboechialgie
kann man sagen, dass der Patient das hat.
Ja.
Würden Sie behaupten, eine Lumboechialgie,
Rückenschmerz wird Ausstrahlung in dem Bein.
Aber dann kann man sagen, äh ...
der Pferenzialdiagnistisch, denke ich an,
Bandscheid, Discosprolaps, äh ...
Ostia, Chondrosa,
Spondylatrosa und so weiter.
Spondylolistesis, genau, kann man auch sagen.
Ja, und Stenose, Spnastenose.
Spnastianose, kann das auch sein.
Äh, pathologische Flaktur, kann es auch sein.
Ja.
Span ...
Ah, kann man auch, ja ...
Man kann, aber durch die Anamese kann man es ausschließen,
wahrscheinlich, weil er keine Gehstreckenminderung hat.
Das haben Sie gefragt, z.B. PRVK, kann man ja ausschließen.
Ja.
Sie haben auch gefragt, ob Temperaturen unterschiedlich sind
oder so, das haben Sie ausgeschlossen.
Ja, ist ja ein, das habe ich gefühlt.
Jetzt habt ihr eine Verdachtdiagnose,
dass jemand eventuell eine Bandscheidungsverfall herben könnte.
Was würden Sie veranlassen?
Was veranlasst ihr, wie gehen Sie voran?
Was würden Sie als Erstes machen?
Ja, erst würde ich ...
der Patienten körperlich untersuchen und dann ...
Den Patienten ausführlich körperlich untersuchen.
Ausführlich körperlich untersuchen.
Und durchschauen?
Durch, ja.
Ich würde bei der Patienten Blut abnehmen,
besonders Entzündungsparameter.
Also, vielen als die Diagnose. Was fällt Ihnen ein?
Um eine Artritis ...
auszuschließen.
Oder um eine Spondritis ...
Und Zulatitis oder so, ja, genau. Okay.
Ja.
Um eine Entzündungsparameter zu schließen.
Okay, weiter.
Ja.
Dann würde ich eine Rötgen in zwei Ebenen entlassen.
Äh, falsch.
Ah.
Sie würden eine Röntgen in zwei Ebenen entlassen.
Moment, noch mal.
Sagen Sie den Satz noch mal, bitte.
Ja, ich würde ein Röntgen in zwei Ebenen entlassen.
Entlassen.
Ja, entlassen.
Entlassen ist, wenn der Patient im Krankenhaus liegt
und ich entlasse ihm nach Hause.
Per anlassen.
Per anlassen, ja, ich würde ihn sehen.
Per anlassen oder durchführen lassen.
Ja, per anlassen.
Aber wenn man sagt, Röntgen, Per anlassen, das ist richtig.
Aber es ist besser, wenn Sie sagen, was Sie Röntgen würden.
Zum Beispiel, ich würde eine Röntgenaufnahme der Lendenwirbelsäule
in zwei Ebenen durchführen lassen oder veranlassen.
Auch beschreiben Sie bitte auch, welche Region das ist.
Okay.
In den Wirbelsäulen.
LBS in zwei Ebenen, Röntgen, Knieglek in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen, passt alles in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen, HWS in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen, Fuß in zwei Ebenen.
Wiederhole das, dass es bei Ihnen ein bisschen einbrennt?
Ja, ich würde ein Röntgen in
Röntgen in zwei Ebenen veranlassen.
Genau. Aber welchen Röntgen? Es gibt ja drei.
Ah, Lendenwirbelsäule.
Ja, Lendenwirbelsäule, genau.
Lendenwirbelsäule.
Genau.
Ja, so, dann würde ich
eine MRT durchführen.
Durchführen.
Würden Sie durchführen oder lassen Sie es beim Radiologen durchführen?
Ja, durchführen lassen.
Ja, okay.
Ja, so.
Was ist da, warum machen Sie eine Aufnahme
oder warum machen Sie beides, warum nicht nur MRT, LBS?
Ich würde mit Röntgen eine
Bruch- oder Osteoporos auslösen, aber bei MRT würde ich
beurteilen, ob eine
Nervenwürzelkompression gibt
oder
Pathologie beim Nerven gibt.
Okay.
Aber ein Bruch kann man auch in einem
MRT besser beurteilen.
Ja, aber
ein Röntgen ist einfacher durchzuführen.
Nicht einfacher, ich weiß, was Sie meinen,
aber ich würde sagen nicht einfacher, sondern es ist eine,
auch noch schnell durchgeführt werden kann
und ein MRT-Termin zu bekommen, auch in einem Klinik,
der ein MRT hat, ist es nicht schnell zu bekommen.
Ja.
Sie wollen ja ganz schnell zu einer Diagnostik kommen.
Auch,
weil Sie vorhin gesagt haben, die meisten Krankenhäuser
nicht alle haben ein MRT.
Das Problem ist, es gibt einen MRT und es gibt sehr viele
Krankheiten, sehr viele kranke Menschen und Kranken aus.
Das heißt, da wird nach Dringlichkeit des MRT durchgeführt.
Es gibt Leute, die zerevalene Blutung haben
oder andere Erkrankungen haben, die wichtiger sind.
Deswegen ein MRT für Orthopädie ist meistens
in ersten paar Tagen zu bekommen.
Das heißt, wenn ein Patient
direkt da ist, macht man gerne ein MRT,
ein Röntgen, weil es eine schnelle Information gibt.
Man kann einige Sachen gewinnen.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, was ich da sehen kann in einem MRT?
Bei MRT?
Ja, Entschuldigung, bei einem Röntgen.
Als Beispiel, so ein paar Sachen.
Was können Sie sagen?
Ja, kann man Knurren brauchen.
Ein Knurrbruch könnte man sehen? Ja, was noch?
Sehen, man kann eine Osteroporos bestimmen.
Nein, nicht immer.
Nicht genau, aber kann man eine Viertagsauf Osteroporos...
Ja, könnte man. Was noch?
Ja, so kann man auch eine...
ob eine Spondylistasis oder...
ob Kyphos Scoliosis gibt bei Thailand.
Und Scoliosis, genau. Das ist richtig.
Die Stellung der Webil Lendelbümensolle ist richtig.
Man kann den Bandscheibenfach sehen,
ob der...
Schmaler ist oder nicht, zum Beispiel.
Genau.
Vielleicht eigentlich schon. Okay.
Im MRT sieht man halt einige Sachen mehr,
aber die kriegt man nicht immer schnell.
Sei es ambulant ist.
Im Krankenhaus ist es egal, ob jemand privat ist oder nicht.
Weil Sie vorhin gesagt haben, Privatpatienten.
Im Krankenhaus kriegt nur der MRT,
jene, der je nach klinischer Dringlichkeit
wird es eine Reihe voll gegeben.
Im ambulanten Bereich ist es so,
leider so, dass wenn man privat für sich hat,
das kriegt man schnelleren Termin.
Sehr schnell.
Warum? Wissen Sie, warum?
Ich glaube, wegen dieser Krankenkasse.
Nee, nicht wegen der Krankenkasse,
sondern wegen dem Geld.
Ein Privatpatient bezahlt für ein MRT, LWS,
ungefähr 400 bis 600 Euro.
Er kriegt eine...
Er kriegt das von der private Päsicherung zurück.
In der Regel.
Und die gesetzliche Präsicherung gibt,
weiß ich nicht, so etwa 150 Euro.
Das heißt, ein Privatpatient gibt mehr Geld.
Und der Privatpatient, wenn Sie einen Termin in vier Wochen geben,
geht er zur nächsten Praxis.
Und dann sagt er, ich will ein MRT,
da kriegt er weit mehr Geld, gibt...
Ah. Okay.
Termin.
Präsentiererprüfung, kann man das erwähnen oder nicht?
Muss man nicht erwähnen?
Nein, nein, nein. Ich würde privat gesetzlich überhaupt nicht erwähnen.
Das ist egal.
Sie sind ja in der Klinik, die fragen den Oberarzt,
in der Klinik ist es egal ob private oder nicht private.
Das Problem ist, es gibt sehr viele Patienten im Krankenhaus,
sehr viele akute Fälle,
weil deswegen sind sie im Krankenhaus,
es ist ein Akutskrankenhaus in der Regel.
Und dort kriegt man nach Dringlichkeit.
Und da lenden wir Besäule,
wenn nichts lebensbedrohtlich ist,
dann kriegt er auch nicht einen schnellen Termin.
Da wird gewartet, bis eine Lücke entstehen.
Es sei denn, jemand gibt eine Paräse an.
Eine OP-Indikation ist eine Paräse.
Ja, Paräse und Kontin.
Ihre Patient eine Paräse hat,
da müssen sie dem Radiologen sagen,
ich brauche dringend einen MRT,
muss jetzt nicht gleich sein, aber heute,
weil ich eventuell operieren werde,
weil das von diesem MRT abhängt,
ob das durch den Discosprolaps bekommen ist oder nicht,
oder was anderes ist.
Ich brauche auch einen dringlichen Termin,
nicht keinen Notfall, aber dringlich.
Dann kriegen sie auch innerhalb eines Tages vielleicht einen Termin.
Und so ist der Orthopäne nicht unbedingt schnell Termin,
immer der Letzte.
Ja.
Okay.
Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen ausgeschreift,
ein bisschen anders erklärt.
So, nehmen wir mal an,
dieser, die Patient hat einen Bandscheimvorfall,
der hat ja keine Nervenausfälle,
was empfehlen Sie Ihren Patienten?
Was würden Sie sagen, okay,
Sie haben einen Bandscheimvorfall.
Ja, Sie ist.
Der Wurzelkompassionssyndrom auf L5.
Recht.
Was empfehlen Sie Ihren Patienten?
Ja, zuerst, er ist ja 35.
Ich würde zuerst Reduktion des Körpergewichts
empfehlen.
Dann,
ja, ich würde empfehlen,
die Akut jetzt ein Kilo kann er nicht in ein,
zwei Tagen abnehmen.
Ich würde erst mal empfehlen,
was wir jetzt machen.
Also empfehlen heißt auch,
ich würde Sie rapieren, wie?
Ich würde non-steroidal,
analgetikum non-steroidal.
Nicht.
Steroidal.
Warum non-steroidal?
Ja, nicht.
Non-indertikal, nicht.
Ja, nicht steroidal Antiflamatöre,
dragon empfehlen.
Dann würde ich
Thermotherapie oder Elektrotherapie
oder Krankengymnastik
empfehlen.
Ja, und man kann auch
narkotik, analgetikum wie
kontramal empfehlen.
Ja, wie ich
wie Sie erwähnt haben, wenn man
in Kontinence oder
Parästhesie oder unerträglich Menschen
haben, muss man
operiert werden.
Wollte man ja. Also, ich, der Mann,
aber Sie haben mir an einem Nestig gesagt,
der Patient hat ja keine
Parästhesie, der hat keine
Paräse und so weiter.
Also, der hat einen Bandscharm Vorfall,
also ist die erste Therapie.
Steroidal oder auch non-steroidal.
Also, man kann auch
Steroidal Therapie geben, also
Cortison Therapie auch geben.
Beides, man kann zusätzlich noch
Analgetika geben, als Schmerztherapie.
Also, zum Beispiel Novalgien,
Parastemol IV zum Beispiel,
kann man auch zu sich im
Tramal, kann man geben.
Also, das ist ja nicht
Steroidal oder
Steroidal, nicht Steroidal,
also NSR oder
Steroidal. Unabhängig kann man
zusätzlich das dazu geben.
Physiotherapien kann man machen,
das stimmt. Was könnte man
noch machen, zum Beispiel
konservativ?
Thermotherapie oder Elektrotherapie.
Ja, das gehört zu physikalischen
Therapiebereich. Was könnten
Sie also machen?
Ja, kalt oder wemme Therapie.
Infiltration könnten Sie machen?
Anesthesie kann man.
Anesthesie oder lokale
Steroidal, also
Triamzine Lohn zum Beispiel,
kristallinhaltige Cortisongabe
könnten Sie geben.
Periratikulär zum Beispiel,
man kann dir auch CT gesteuert
geben, dann nennt man das PRT.
CT gesteuerte PRT,
periratikuläre Infiltration
zum Beispiel mit Triamzine Lohn.
Also kristallinhaltige
Cortison.
Ja.
Okay.
Und
die Therapie,
Therapieresistent ist,
also wenn es nicht viel bringt,
die Lebensgrund,
unter den starken Massnahmen
Cortison und Ohne Cortison,
Steroidal oder nicht Steroidal
und Physiotherapie, wenn es nicht
hilft und die MRT-Aufnahme
zeigt auch, dass es ein
Wurzelkompissons-Zyndrom ist,
in dem Bereich L5.
Ja, in dem Bereich L5.
Dann kann man auch eine OP
empfehlen sozusagen.
Aber erst, wenn eine Therapieresistenz
vorliegt.
Ja, Therapieresistenz.
Ja.